hey everybody welcome to the great big
story YouTube channel I'm Jillian I'm
Dave welcome to the show today we're
looking at four stories about people who
are dreaming big and our first story is
about a woman who is a bodybuilder but a
little different than the one you might
expect keep an eye out for the heels
I am Ernestine shepherd 80 years of age
i benchpress
110 pounds I started training at age 71
I was named the oldest female
competitive bodybuilder at the Guinness
Book of World Records
my sister and I started exercising
together I had never done any type of
exercising before before she died she
said promise me you will follow my dream
and try to get in the Guinness Book of
World Records so that's what I did
[Music]
I have been in six or seven competition
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
[Music]
I'm up every morning at 2:30 after I
have my devotion I walk and I run
approximately 10 miles I'm at the gym at
7:30 and I have a group of ladies that
I've trained down why I trained all ages
one of the youngest I think is about 20
years ago
and the rest go from 14 all the way up
to a
when people come to my class for the
very first time they are really really
surprised face it I didn't think this
exercise would be this tough but you can
do it we are going to do it too
I really don't feel as though I'm 18
years of age but I am I want to keep
training until my day is done
[Music]
for our next story we are going to take
a little trip around the globe and go to
Nepal this story is about a guy who is
the oldest student in his class by a
long shot
due to an EF no God no that would be no
cars aboard our endeavours in math I do
justice Amira Varma for Bambi hunting
school Madan - mera naam the gigantic
class - Neronian 59
[Music]
agonda beach nude larger that was
instrumental starboard is routine sir
[Music]
morning everybody to go madam one
wannabe say when you go semaj Agra is an
essential human demand for them Mohan
dhaba
Sano America sorrow sorrow vitamin e
serve Allah - and Yoda must be deadly to
a dissident water source of 11 - well I
have time for some women sat huge hitter
football helena bonham alarm on further
medieval can happen in one quarter I
mean a solution era mass no as molasses
on pesky version verdict anemic Varma's
look is vegan talaga - caliber a low
vegan homogeny Gamakatsu forces and a
mineral act of romantic uh namely
thousand anybody for the virtue and say
we formalize Jerry algorithm for
normalization bersama
his full greatness that is cool logic
tiene
and he for me when we broke open more to
eternity together my diggity Mulligan
era
Humira normalize any survey de Medici
Chapel era Duty Tejano colliding with
over some over a city for no for the
rada'han air america Barilla yoga you
know balls
varam local iv7 Emily Rasta in terrassa
Sabatini hollow Bugaboo new ba ba la
villita
elusive element admirable quality who
for no pony Riga and fedora in German I
have a family
machine pistol noble animal
[Music]
our next story is about a guy who fought
to serve both his country and his faith
his name's captain Singh and he has
quite a story Sikhism is the Ewell's
fifth largest religion a ceased uniform
right a beard and turban and all the
articles of faith when I wear them I'm
representing equality justice fairness
I'm telling the world that this is what
I stand for and this is what I will
fight for a Sikh would rather lose his
head than lilius turban I'm some earth
boxing I'm captain in the US Army and
I'm also seasoned when I found out that
I could not serve with the articles of
faith that was a shock to me Sikhs and
military service school hand-in-hand
my great-grandfather served in war one
for the British Indian Army there's no
conflict between what six valleys are
and the Army Values I started my
military career at West Point when I was
18 I knew I was going to make a big
decision of walking away from articles
of faith the grooming standards as far
as shaving more codified so that
everyone the military soldiers looked
the same and I was standing in line
right outside the barber shop and
thinking well here it is right and I sat
down and and the ladies of the
barbershop were surprised I am longer I
had always my back I don't know if they
understood what was going on my entire
life was changing and everything my
self-image everything was being
shattered and that's when I had to make
a decision right and the decision I made
was I'm going to choose to serve my
country and figure out a way to come
back to my articles of faith later on
it was after I met the two gentlemen who
were wearing their articles of faith and
were in the army and I learned that
there is a way to request religious
accommodation I was simply asking for
what I believe were all my rights and
March 31st was when I received the
permanent accommodation and I had a
positive thing that 10 years later 10
years later it finally happened the
first day that I wore my uniform I was
not very certain it was an unreal unreal
feeling
when I look at a mirror now I feel a
sense of pride and completeness my two
walls have come together sometimes to
achieve your dreams you need a co-pilot
like in rally car baby buckle up
[Music]
35 minutes or Internet by car back door
down the most unique part of rally car
racing is if a regular person were to
hear the in-car audio of a driver and a
co-driver it would seem like they were
speaking gibberish
in actuality it's a language that tells
that driver what is coming next they
really are just the eyes for the driver
before they can get to that spot
[Music]
rally car racing in America is stage
racing that you can have anywhere from
12 to 14 stages anywhere from six to
twenty miles in some cases I mean you're
racing other competitors but really it's
you against the clock so inside of a
rally car we have two people we have a
driver and a co-driver the driver drives
the car tries to keep it on the road
without wrecking it and the co-driver is
responsible for reading the notes 50
turn a left 3 tighten the right three -
no cut so for this example we have 50
here so that means before the next note
I call you'll have 50 meters and then
key for me stands for turn which means
you'll change roads from the road that
you're currently on and then a left
three left obviously means your corner
is going to go to the left and a three
is the degree of the corner there's so
much information to take in from the
co-driver you stay 120 miles over a
weekend it could be as many as two to
three thousand different commands that
co-driver is reading the driver it's
pretty much that co-driver
is the computer of that car he or she is
going to get you from point A to point B
and as a driver you need to trust what
that co-driver is telling you we started
as a team when I was 15 and sometimes I
feel like I can simply read his mind I
really trust what she is telling me to
the point where if I had to close my
eyes and maybe not drive it race speed
she could tell me pace notes and I could
still drive blind right up to 70
right for long time I mean right to
freakin turn luxurious camp
to a careless three-tails turn
[Music]
very nice
rallies let me see how you know one of
my children has grown up and how they
become if I looked at her as a co-driver
and not a not a daughter or a relative I
I'd grab her in a heartbeat
I'd love to make it a full-time career
one day and rally internationally and
I'd love to just follow my dad's
footsteps
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed watching these
great big stories with us don't forget
to subscribe by clicking the horse and
make sure to leave us a comment down
below so we know what you're thinking
see you next time bye guys